Berlin's museum Island currently boasts
an additional and rather unconventional
tourist attraction the stars of this
show are men like Frank Andrus every day
he plunges into the river spray to
explore the construction pit next to the
world-famous pergamon museum and to
remove old chunks of concrete another
rubble and a 9 meters underwater
visibility is basically zero for the
next two hours a diving telephone will
be Anders's soul connection to the
outside world the hose his only source
of air the site boss himself has 27
years of diving experience under his
belt and appreciates the challenges
facing his men the oldest all wasn't you
feel the divers see with their fingers
they also have to use their fingers to
find out what the situation is like down
there there's a bolt or a wooden stake
or whatever and what they have to be
able to picture and describe things by
feeling them old Nazi invest honest
the diver uses a compressed air Lance to
blast old concrete debris from the walls
the Lance shoots out a jet of 190 litres
of water per minute it's a highly
specialized instrument that demands
specialized skills what does later you
don't miss um you have to keep your mind
focused especially when you're working
with compressed air one slip of
attention can make things really
dangerous ok let's encounter this guy
can pose a danger but only to
unauthorized visitors to the company HQ
Costin Leonard launched his company as a
one-man operation 23 years ago and now
employs 30 people the company is one of
the leaders in its field in Germany
Frank undress and his colleagues
practice regularly in a diving tank
today he's donned a 70 kilo diving suit
for a training video the tank features a
welcome difference to real-life
conditions clear visibility all the way
to the bottom six meters down the boss
tags along to capture the action on
video Andres now has to weld a joint
underwater that many colleagues wouldn't
manage on dry land on site of course
he'll be practically working blind in
the murky water let skipton was lighted
you some people in the trade are good at
other jobs I am some to a lot of welding
you know you need both experience and
dexterity other go to Bob thousand be
Tom's way you need to have a few
thousand meters of joint welding to do a
job like this one right it's also what
up you know you know what is it nice
the museum Island project is one of the
biggest jobs Leonard's company has ever
had his operation includes four floating
platforms each with three divers
assigned besides welding they also have
to salvage debris by hand like these oak
tree piles remnants of a previous
structure from centuries back the divers
have an extremely demanding job and an
exhausting one with shifts lasting up to
12 hours a day I can't expect them to do
more than is absolutely necessary if
they don't feel good that's clear the
success or failure of the operation and
ultimately this company depends on these
specialists both 11 time and off de
forma the next step for the divers is to
cast foundations for a new reception
area for their museum Island due to open
in three years time
you